so much has happened since I saw you I  lost my hammer like yesterday sir but  still pretty fresh then I went on a  journey of self-discovery I love you  [Music]  where are we you have no idea however  God is the death is invaded as God oh I  miss this  and you know how to fight night  [Music]  now I want easily sound right Oh  [Music]  God is dead little be reborn in my image  I thought you'd be glad to see me  need a stopper here and now prevent  Ragnarok the end of everything  so I'm putting together a team  at the old days  supplies it'll be such fun  hi  he's a fighter  here we go  I'm not a queen or a monster  I'm the goddess of death  what were you to god all again  [Music]  we're the same unite just to come huntin  fools  yes saying all kite fire door like water  I can't cuz I fire the whole quick  raging fire so I like smoldering fire  you  you